it's been over three years since the
release of Star Wars Jedi Fallen order
and even more time has passed in the
story between it and its sequel Star
Wars Jedi Survivor here's everything you
need to know for the next major release
from respawn entertainment including the
lore to catch you up on what is what and
who is whom
before we get started on setting up the
story of Jedi Survivor just know that
this video will contain spoilers for the
events of the previous game Jedi Fallen
order as well as some of the highlights
of the high Republic era of which this
latest installment will heavily tie into
Star Wars Jedi Survivor like its
predecessor is focused on Cal castis a
Padawan during the Clone Wars that
managed to escape from the clutches of
the newly minted Empire and Order 66
which saw clone troopers previously
under the command of the Jedi turn on
the force users five years later Cal
successfully remains hidden as a
scrapper on the planet Baraka until an
accident that almost claims his friend's
life forces the young Jedi to save him
with his powers revealing his identity
to Witnesses now hunted by inquisitors
Cal is rescued by former Jedi Knight sir
junda and griez draitus pilot of their
ship the stingamantis sear takes Cal to
the point planets bogano where her
former Master Ino Cordova hit a Jedi
holocron in a vault containing a list of
force sensitive children that Sia
believes could help rebuilds the Jedi
Order to access the Vault so the crew
must follow the path of Cordova
accompanied by bd1 an adorable Droid and
former companion of the deceased Jedi
Master Kell's Quest takes him to several
planets including the Wookie Homeworld
of kashyyk and dathomir the birthplace
of iconic Sith Lords Darth Maul as well
as a knight sister known as Marin whom
joins the crew of the stingamantis after
Cal helps her take down malikos a former
Jedi Master who succumbed to the dark
side Cal also learns that The Inquisitor
leading the hunt for him is Trilla Sears
former Padawan that she gave up when
interrogated by the Empire Trilla
naturally holds some resentment over her
former mentor's betrayal once Cal
completes his and obtains the Jedi
holocron he has a vision of what could
come to pass if he were to rebuild the
Jedi Order namely its destruction at the
hands of the Empire and his turn to the
dark side before he can figure out what
to do trila shows up and steals the
Hologram Cal breaks into the
inquisitor's headquarters the aptly
named Fortress inquisitorius where he
confronts Trilla retrieves the holocron
and with the help of seer is able to
bring her former Padawan back to the
side of the light for a brief moment
before Darth Vader shows up and takes
her out for failing him no match for the
Sith Lord Cal and Seer make their escape
and when they return to Pagano Cal makes
the executive decision to destroy the
holocron and the information within it
lest his Bleak Vision come to pass Jedi
Survivor takes place another five years
after Fallen order putting it right
around the events of the Disney Plus
show Obi-Wan Kenobi in the timeline and
nine years before or episode 4 A New
Hope since the end of the first title
The Crew has been perpetrating acts of
rebellion against the empire some of
which are detailed in the tie-in novel
Star Wars Jedi Battle Scars that takes
place in between the two games it's in
this novel that we learn of how Cal gets
his literal facial scars that we see in
Jedi Survivor as well as why gries's
upper right arm is now robotic however
the crew has since gone their separate
ways as Cal continues to fight the good
fight but sear gries and Marin have
seemingly lost the spark details on
exactly what might have happened to
break the crew up as well as what
happens in the game to bring them back
together are sparse before the game's
release we do know however of two of The
Game's antagonists what many fans
initially believed from the first
trailer to be the grand Inquisitor is
actually an imperial Senator albeit one
of the same power and race another enemy
seen in several trailers for the game is
Ravis the powerful gendai race nearly
Immortal beings made entirely of
tendrils their humanoid structure given
form by their armor the gendai made
their first appearance in Gandhi
tartakovsky's excellent limited-run
Clone Wars series his name serving as
the inspiration for theirs the final
major antagonist we've seen in trailers
has clothing tying him to the high
Republic era seemingly a Jedi
disappointed in how the order allowed
for the rise of the empire we've since
learned from our own preview of the game
that this time period will heavily tie
into survivor's story considering that
the high Republic is very new to the
Canon and has yet to be detailed outside
of several Books and Comics here is some
top level information of that era
while the high Republic has only been a
thing for a few years and so far only
been explored in literary formats it has
also been surveyed in great detail the
high Republic starts hundreds of years
prior to episode 1 The Phantom Menace
and ends several decades before it is
named as such because it is seen as the
golden age for not only the Republic but
also the Jedi the Light Side Force
wielders were flourishing while the Sith
were basically non-existent not
everything was pod racing and sabach at
this time however as a Marauder group
called The Nigh Hill under the
leadership of Martian row sought to grow
its influence in the Galaxy the conflict
between the Jedi and the nihil served
for much of the storytelling we've had
so far during this time period what made
the nihil such a threat was their
ability to navigate the paths routes
through hyperspace that only the nihil
had learned how to navigate consider
considering Carl's line from Jedi
Survivor story trailer of I think we
finally found somewhere the Empire can't
reach us the paths could be incredibly
relevant to the game while the high
Republic has only been explored in Books
and Comics so far it is about to move
into other mediums such as animation
with young Jedi Adventures releasing May
4th 2023 as well as live action in the
acolyte series also dropping on Disney
Plus in 2024
gameplay in Star Wars Jedi Survivor will
build off of and expand upon what was
possible in Jedi Fallen order thankfully
game director Stig as musin has
confirmed that the title won't reset
Cal's powers and many of the abilities
and techniques he had cultivated by the
end of the previous game will be present
at the start of Jedi Survivor Cal will
also at points be able to perform combo
attacks with companions the trailers
showing the Jedi partnering up with
Marin as well as both Acuna a new
character being introduced in the game
that has major Han Solo Vibes and that
Cal forms a special bond with according
to asmussen since Cal isn't losing any
of his abilities from the end of the
previous title he will start with the
option to form both a standard and
double-sided lightsaber while in Jedi
Fallen order Kal could split the
double-sided variant into two separate
Sabers as a limited time attack in Jedi
Survivor dual wielding lightsabers has
become its own form the single-sided
lightsaber is an overall balanced option
the double-sided lightsaber is meant for
crowd control and dual wielding has a
focus on speed over time Cal will be
able to expand his Arsenal to allow for
two additional forms cross guard and
Blaster the cross guard lightsaber
sacrifices speed in favor of heavier
attacks the Blaster stance will allow
Cal to wield both a blaster and a
lightsaber in terms of gameplay the
Blaster expands Cal's options for ranged
attacks Beyond just chucking his blade
or using his force abilities speaking of
force abilities Cal's got some new ones
these included the ability to freeze
Blaster bolts as well as perform a
mid-air Force stash to make certain
jumps Cal will also be able to connect
with various creatures through the force
allowing him to use them as mounts to
Traverse the game's more expansive
locales
Jedi Survivor Cal will be exploring
familiar locations as well as totally
brand new ones one of the most important
ones which served as the planet for a
Hands-On preview is Kobo in Jedi Fallen
order the stingamantis served as Cal's
home base in Jedi Survivor his home base
is now a full settlement called
rambler's reach on Kobo centering around
a Cantina run by Greece characters that
cow meets on his adventures can set up
shop in rambler's reach offering him
sidequests new dialogue options and
purchases such as cosmetic items which
have greatly expanded in Jedi Survivor
to include swapping out pods for bd1
hair and beard styles for Cal and more
diverse clothing options that's right
Cal can wear more than just a poncho
this time around while the majority of
places Cal will be visiting during Jedi
Survivor are still a mystery ahead of
its launch one of the planets he will go
to is one that Star Wars fans are
already very familiar with might be the
game's most exciting Coruscant
Star Wars Jedi Survivor will be released
on April 28 2023 with the standard
edition priced at 70 the game will be
coming to the latest generation of
Hardware only which means the
PlayStation 5 Xbox series X and S and PC
pre-ordering the game will net you some
in-game Cosmetics inspired by the
Obi-Wan Kenobi show such as the former
Jedi Masters outfit and lightsaber hilt
and the combustion Blaster utilized
before returning to his elegant weapon
for a more civilized age a digital
deluxe edition priced at 90 will also
come with an assortment of in-game
Cosmetics the new hero cosmetic pack
includes an outfit reminiscent of Luke's
garments from when he receives a medal
at the very end of episode 4 A New Hope
an R2D2 inspired colorway for bd1 and
his lightsaber hilt the galactic hero
cosmetic pack is Han Solo themed with
his outfit from A New Hope a rugged bd1
colorway and his dl-44 Blaster and
because you're wondering yes there was a
physical collector's edition of The Game
featuring a steelbook case and Cal
castis's lightsaber hilt and was made
via limited run games but this option
was limited to only 5 000 orders and has
unfortunately already sold out that's
everything to know about Star Wars Jedi
Survivor the second game in the Jedi
series that asmussen states he intended
to ultimately be a Trilogy will this
game be The franchise's Empire Strikes
Back we'll find out when it releases on
April 28th